the alternative
the alternative for germany
is committed to both ecological
as well as to modern conventional agriculture
but i ask you at this point
especially the colleagues with the Green
please do not fuel polarization here
it already goes through our society a crack
we prevent
that this crack
also goes across agriculture
the goals of the federal government
the share of organic farming
to expand we do not share
it is not decisive
whether food from organic
or conventional production come
the quality is crucial
and resource efficiency
dear colleagues the good professional practice
that is what counts on the farms